State of the Union address was tonight
yeah sure
y'all watched it right well no that's
not fair cuz we tape before the State of
the Union address so I just made the
audience look like they don't care about
it Union vest no I think you've found
exactly the level of enthusiasm people
are feeling towards this event yeah
excite about that say the you dress huh
that's all you have to do yeah
earlier tonight president Trump gave his
State of the Union address and as per
tradition someone who opposes the
president gave the rebuttal yeah so this
year's rebuttal was given by Melania I
don't like him and Trump said he now
supports he now supports a plan for
young immigrants to become citizens yeah
yeah when asked why Trump said cuz I may
have to look for a new wife soon so
[Applause]
I think she's gonna come to the address
tonight that's what they're saying
that's what there's yeah she hasn't been
seen since she somebody s she's been
hiding out since the stormy stormy
Daniels storm and you're thinking of the
rum drink not the porn snow hey guess
what Bernie Sanders also gave a rebuttal
to Trump speech yeah
yes Sanders speech lasted 20 minutes
with to pee breaks so that's my Bernie
Sanders right there doing this president
Trump's approval rating is above 50% in
just a handful of states yeah
those states include Georgia Mississippi
and denial
[Applause]
you